c'est en 2018 pour le 170e anniversaire
de l'abolition de l'esclavage que le
département a lancé le grand chantier
qui fera du musée historique de Villèle
le musée de l'habitation et de
l'esclavage l'ancien domaine colonial
qui est emblématique de l'histoire de la
traite et de l'esclavage à La Réunion
sera demain après de longs et lourds
travaux le lieu de référence pour
connaître et étudier cette page
d'histoire
le chantier est grand et multiple il
prendra plusieurs années il concerne
naturellement le site lui-même ces
bâtiments ces vestiges sont paysages ces
traces immatérielles il concerne aussi
la préparation des futurs contenus du
musée et il construit peu à peu son
réseau de partenaires
chaque grand va descendre est l'occasion
pour le département de faire le point de
l'avancée du chantier le projet du musée
concernera les 10 hectares du site pour
raconter de la façon la plus complète
possible le système esclavagiste et le
fonctionnement d'une habitation le site
a d'ailleurs été totalement classé
monument historique en 2019
les skis du projet a été choisi en 2020
et depuis le 20 décembre 2021 une
maquette est exposée au musée accessible
à tous ces publics
cette année un avant projet sommaire a
été remis au département par l'équipe de
maîtrise d'oeuvre et sera finalisée en
2023 en attendant le chantier devient
visible grâce au premier chantier
archéologique lancé en octobre ce sont
les anciens magasins qui inaugurent
cette campagne de fouilles avec les
écuries le parc boeuf et le poulailler
de l'habitation
deux autres fouilles suivront en 2022 et
investiront la cuisine le Gaudon et
surtout l'ancienne usine à sucre pour
enrichir le discours du futur musée un
autre programme de recherche a été
initié en 2022 porté par l'association
quand vilaine avec le soutien du
Département il vise à collecter la
mémoire d'une vingtaine de gramouns qui
ont connu la période du Colonna
ces témoignages d'acteurs directs de
l'histoire intègreront les archives du
Musée dans le même esprit le portail
esclavage réunion s'est enrichi de
nouveautés ce sont plus d'une
soixantaine de contributeurs du monde de
la recherche ou de la culture qui sont
aujourd'hui disponibles sur le site le
département l'avait annoncé d'emblée le
musée de l'habitation et de l'esclavage
sera un musée ouvert ouvert sur son
quartier avec son école ses associations
ses acteurs économiques le dialogue se
déploie tout au long de l'année et
notamment lors des événements portés par
le musée ouvert sur la réunion sur le
monde de la recherche de la culture des
entreprises du sport travaux d'écriture
pour les uns accueille en résidence pour
les autres consolidation du mécénat et
des projets en commun le département
oeuvre constamment au rassemblement de
la réunion autour de son histoire et de
son
celui-ci multiplie les contacts avec les
pays de l'Océan Indien et de l'Afrique
en 2022 les travaux ont concerné le
Mozambique et l'Afrique du Sud ils vont
être amplifiés grâce à la nomination
d'un chargé des Relations extérieures au
sein du musée avec la France au-delà des
relations avec la Fondation pour la
mémoire de l'esclavage des contacts sont
pris avec les institutions culturelles
incontournables dans la thématique de
l'esclavage et puis lors d'un colloque
organisé à Charleston en Caroline du Sud
le musée historique de Villèle a été
heureux de présenter une version
spéciale de l'exposition consacrée à
Furcy